what's up reject nation I'm Greg that's
Olivia this is John we are going to
watch stranger things episode 4 of s3
otherwise known as three by four if
you've heard me give this whole spiel
before it's up to you if you want to
listen to it make sure to subscribe and
click that notification Valley get
notified when our next stranger things
reaction is up subscribe buttons don't
do as much as notification bells do
secondly I want to thank Eric over at
nerd cronic for editing down the
highlights for us because YouTube only
allows for 10-minute reaction highlights
but the fooling stream along for all our
stranger thinks episodes are all going
up at our patreon page speaking of our
patreon page we do stream along for many
shows that includes Gotham haunting a
hill house Cobra Kai season 2 and some
of the shows that we cover we do stream
longs for and they also have reaction
highlights as well those are my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man attack on
Titan and supernatural Eric make sure to
give this guy a follow at nerd cronic
he's done work for people like Hassan
eiements know movie trivia Schmo down he
has his own podcast forever podcasts are
found and on YouTube as well they have
social media let's hop into this now
shall we
wonder wonder woman Heather had fever so
she took back she's better now it has to
be nothing weird goes on a rocket we saw
wrong wrong this kind of like his
default but it's nice to know he's not a
murderer he's actually sucked it was big
lab your last episode was like so not
him no he wasn't making fun of you
[Music]
that is so cool
we need one of those
how many times you believe this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whatever diet is something the two of
you doesn't devalue a whole lot
both
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] weird Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you just continue in convince yourself
what's that supposed to mean
I told you over and over to talk this
story just like Bruce and those [ __ ]
[ __ ] knew this job is that was not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this machine talking about really does
exist and the reason that we do find at
the labs because now the lab is one of
these
[Music]
so loud this world it beats you up again
and again until eventually most people
they just just stopped right you're a
fighter
you always happen I honestly don't know
where you go have sex with building to
break it enter some women supporting
women this season of stranger things
beautiful thing you're the most
important thing to me in the world what
she's right what no no he's just some
angry old man it's joy but if I really
see you and I'm a different species than
you then I should be with my species
more did you spy on me
benefits practicing honey the whole room
used to be dedicated to that mug shot
but not before she takes down a Russian
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
resist about gloves know what
Hey
I predict you know Steve Steve is the
audience
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my
oh this is going to become their version
15
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
you can so this is like
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yes God how many of them are that
happening God
oh there's no larger today
awesome
[Music]
well I love that episode I thought that
episode was slam tastic ladies and gent
I thought it was great that was great I
mean that whole final sequence was so
damn intense and I love the emotional
wraparound to come down in such
intensity or love and finally pushes him
out to the the wall and then she falls
into Mike's arms like I'm the most
vulnerable stay possible that after all
the anger and hurt that they've been
experiencing with one another it's like
this cool visual moment where they just
fall into each others arms because of a
situation you know that's been little
schwa Shaz the walls literally like
breaking through a wall and they break
it through a wall emotionally I don't
know if that's intentional over me too
much to do ever that's not ready yeah
really steps in to try to help her to
like he picks up the pipe and yeah
Mike's first good and good moment they
let off with that exchange where he
tries to own up and apologize for his
behavior and stuff like that right
before they do the operations does I
guess you could kind of run a parallel
of emotional growth there
yeah and physical violence yeah oh man
dr. Montgomery's Billy it's weird like
he was like such an aggressive rageful
dude in season two a Stephen King Vil
yeah I think because of the context of
his character in season two Tumi's
didn't feel entirely essential to the
bigger picture yeah and there was so
much focus the rage stuff I'm like man
he's doing such a good job but I just
don't see the point of any of this and
then here now I'm like oh he's really
shining now though yeah because there's
so much contrast with the way that he's
like so distraught all the time yeah
wedding is on that soffit remote feels
terrible there are those Body Snatcher
moments where he's like really prim and
proper and and very warm and kind and
weird and like he's good at playing all
those different angles and I have to
imagine this was fun for him shoot cuz
like he just gets to be a monster half
this episode yeah hulking out yeah I
love all those visual moments for him in
a limiter yeah
just keep yelling at each other's it's a
part of this TARDIS thing you guys have
ever
when you see him fighting back against
her and winning you're like oh my god
yeah he could be there is like crazy oh
yeah that was really well choreographed
yeah I'm really a man though the way
this season especially the wasn't the
way they're doing their sound design and
the cinematography I can't get over at
every episo-- I'm just like man this is
the best looking season they've
definitely done more than just like oh
they got a better budget the way it's
composed and I think is the best that's
ever been actually but every story line
here is great even working with Lucas's
sister who's Eric I'm never gonna forget
her name reaction that was magical yeah
cuz he caught me off guard for a second
and then he had the same thought idea
where is it yeah that is true I think we
all did that like they're really good
and you were calling out Steve's like
just reaction stuff and I think one of
the secret ingredients of the show is
they are good at giving a character in
the ensemble your exact thought but this
season feels kind of like it I don't
know how the second half will be but
this feels kind of like an LP we're like
this is the end of side one we just got
to this like major crescendo like even
the music was really like oh [ __ ] just
went down yeah and then you know I
imagine we'll do another slow ramp-up to
the very end
I like Cary Elwes way more this episode
than his last one because he doesn't add
to it yeah every every few years Cary
Elwes looks like that he got older it
was a point where there was a point
where he gained a lot of weight yeah
like it's awesome yeah
I have no idea who is and just I was
like I feel like when he does American
accents if he has to do like these kind
of charming characters it always feels
over-the-top to me just generally
speaking with his performances but when
he has to do moments of like dramatic
weight and intensity I think he does a
really good job some reason when he does
like charming American accent oh my you
so over-the-top I think he's really good
at breaking the illusion - because it's
clear that he and hopper aren't gonna
back down to each other and then finally
hopper has to like really like control
like when his charm goes away he's
really good at that - it like revealing
the guy man I I don't know what's gonna
happen to him and Joyce would like cuz
because they're just so brazen this
episode was removed as Chief of Police
which will take some of his power away
which is of concern and then the public
will turn against him because the lot of
his she stays in Hawkins and he leaves
she brings him on as an intern I think
there's just a lot happening but it all
blends together seamlessly which is
amazing and now there's gonna be no more
Jonathan
there's just gonna be Nancy there's been
like really no definitive lead I feel in
this season everyone really feels like
an ensemble like even Mike
usually has felt like he's the lead yeah
the guy who looks like will but isn't
with yeah but Mike doesn't feel as
fleshed out as he normally is but that
usually comes with the territory of
ensembles with seasons as you eventually
you start giving more lead focus to
other characters we don't know as well
yeah just the way it goes so I'm not
bothered by that but I do love the
dynamic between Joyce and hopper so much
I mean I guess I said we were filming it
I really love how each character because
of the experiences they've had there's
so much less hesitation to take control
of a situation yep in the first season
it's like that of course it is and of
course it is in the second season but at
this point now I'm they have a [ __ ]
problem they're just like let's handle
it do it because of what's gone on in
their lives they know that they have no
choice but prepare
the worst treated as if it's the worst
and take care of it right away I have to
break a few rules like when she rips out
that cord from the phone she's like we
call the police
Wow we know how small towns were yeah
there's that too and you're seeing it
all slowly start to tie in at this point
it's like we have accused as to what's
going we don't exactly know what's going
on with the mind flare it looks like
they're cloning them right it looks like
some type of invasion of the body
snatchers meets like the tethered
disseminating itself into a bunch of
people just - yeah like take over the
world that way yeah it's we're not a
hundred percent sure what's going on yet
there that Rick and Morty episode where
the planet is all one woman and it's
like every different character is just
the same hive mind that's the whole
population of an entire planet now we
know never saw this we watch no concept
are you saying you what I've seen Rick
and Morty I'm not seeing every episode
yeah I thought you actually take it all
back no reference Adventure Time but
have not seen every order but there's
way more of those I've seen most of it
that's a good joke season three
I'm good is it good yes let's review
that show in terms of it all starting to
connect because you see like the whole
Russian thing that's going on with man
Dustin and freaking Steve he steps up
and he's like if you die I would die too
yeah you see that there's something
going on stark or Maul obviously and
then with Mayor Cline and he's revealing
that you know there's something with the
stark or mall and the whole Billy
storyline has yet to completely connect
to it but we know there's something with
the upside down the mind flare so I'm
loving the central focus of all this
whereas I kind of felt like in season
two of some of the storylines are a
little too divided here I think they're
really core Lessing a lot better they're
divided but still connected yeah and
with different types of groups to focus
on at a time and then you know also the
I mean it's the least interesting one
but it's lent itself to a lot of cool
visual motifs I think with
whole thing with the old lady eating the
fertilizer like that was some very
disturbing imagery and I loved a lot of
like you love those Dutch angles
yeah and and I do think that whether or
not the Nancy Jonathan as character's
storyline is compelling I do think that
whenever they check back in on it we get
some kind of neat sci-fi thing out of it
at least you know like yeah kind of
expansion on like I think having that
for example when Billy's freaking out
being able to cut to the hospital and
see the old woman also going to the same
thing like it helps and it's you know
the rats and her eating the fertilizer
and all that stuff like at least we're
getting cool story building with it it
seems like Jonathan's taking a much
bigger backseat in order to give Nancy a
stronger development make her a better
character a stronger character
especially with having that support from
her mom there in that scene which is
really cool really loving this really
loving this anyway we got with four more
episodes left yeah get to it guys let's
model us out all about Jonathan getting
a real yes all right guys well thanks
for watching make sure to subscribe and
click that notification bell that way
you can be notified when our next
stranger things reaction is out make
sure to check us out on patreon and
thank you to everyone a splash our
patreon page so far before I wrap this
up did put out a post before we sort of
filming asking those who are pledge for
the shadow of a war chair who watches
stranger things that have ever liked and
commented once we're gonna get a shout
out in this video and today is gonna go
out to a man named Andrew Nickerson
Andrew Irene they call that the
Nickerson Nickerson I've this I think on
the camera looks closer no you should be
used to me l boo you in the face but I'm
really tired of it
all right fine thank you sir may I have
another
so Andrew Nickerson I wanted to say
thank you so much for pledging my dude
we gave you a really awkward shout out
last time and now I'm gonna give you a
sincere shoutout the man owns a Tesla oh
that is sincere congratulations on your
achievement and for driving an electric
car I guess I just wanted to say that if
you can own a Tesla I don't understand
why your pledge is not the highest out
of everyone on our patreon page do you
know if you sold your Tesla you think
about it weren't you think if you could
be the only person who is real rejects
t-shirts so many Henry you would be the
only person pledge it would take care of
it you could be our boss yeah if you
wanted to literally just do whatever
channel will be run by you every step of
the way because we are willing to be
bought our yeah and will be called the
Nickerson rejects it's got a lot nicer
ring no congratulations I hear you told
me you have a really good job you must
know bad life decision thank you guys